I had a weird experience this weekend
that makes me believe I kind of understand empty nest syndrome a little bit more
I have three little kids
and I homeschool my two older ones
so my house is never devoid of children
I have zero time in my house when the kids are not also at home
but my parents took all three kids for the weekend this weekend
and at first
my husband and I were so psyched that we're gonna get the house alone
because you know
we have these beautiful spaces
but we never get to like
cook and relax and like
actually sit on our couch
so that was our plan for the weekend
that's all we planned on doing is just hanging out and relaxing
tell me why it was so difficult to actually relax in a big empty house
it's almost like all of the stresses and anxieties and like
compulsions that you have within your house
while you're taking care of kids still there
you just have this like
phantom anxiety that the kids aren't there
so although all day every day
we look at our beautiful space and they're like oh
I wish we could sit and enjoy these
when we actually got the opportunity
it was jarring
and I think that's why empty nest feels so weird
cause your body's used to the chaos